bienvenidos de nuevo ya que sabemos
todas las fórmulas para derivar y además
sabemos la regla de la cadena la regla
del producto y la regla del cociente que
hemos visto en los vídeos anteriores
estamos preparados para hacer derivadas
mucho más divertidas sin embargo yo sé
que muchos de ustedes todavía se les
dificulta un poco deriva entonces no
pierdan la paciencia y lo importante es
que sigan practicando hagan muchos
ejercicios y tal vez hasta de manera
monótona pero si ustedes practican mucho
las derivadas después de un tiempo estas
sedes van a ser mucho más sencillas
entonces vamos a seguir practicando en
esta ocasión no voy a tomar la función
se no pero no soy de x seno de una
función para que sea más divertido de la
función 3x a la quinta más 2x como se va
a derivar esta función bueno pues la
derivada de esta función que está un
poco más difícil la voy a hacer por la
regla de la cadena que decía vamos a
derivar la función interna la función
que está dentro de los paréntesis
entonces primero debemos lo que está
dentro de los paréntesis y me da de
resultado 15 x 4a
+ 2 es una derivada de exponentes aquí
no había mucha dificultad y después por
la regla de la cadena hay que derivar la
función externa es decir la función seno
pero puede derivar el seno en el último
vídeo vimos que era la función coseno
coseno de quien a pues de la función
interna tal cual sin derivar el coseno
de 3x quinta más 2x y así de sencillo
utilizando la regla de la cadena y
sabiendo en qué momento se utiliza la
regla de la cadena es muy fácil resolver
derivadas así que vamos a otra derivada
un poco más difícil y también voy a
cambiar de color y de notación para que
se vayan acostumbrando a los distintos
tipos de notación que hay mi segunda
función de este vídeo va a ser que igual
la voy a poner a a la x y esto lo voy a
multiplicar por la función coseno
elevado a la quinta potencia de x esta
función parece bastante desafiante no es
así esperemos que la podamos resolver
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es que
es una multiplicación de funciones
la función de la equis que multiplica a
la función coseno quinto de x por lo
tanto voy a utilizar la regla del
producto entonces la derivada de con
respecto a x fíjense en la anotación de
la derivada es una notación distinta
pero al final está diciendo lo mismo hay
que derivar esta función con respecto a
x quien es pues primero hay que derivar
la primera función y multiplicarla por
la segunda función tal cual pero la
derivada de la x es muy sencilla se
acuerdan era la única función que su
derivada era ella misma entonces es a la
x que multiplica que a la segunda
función sin derivar la ponemos igualita
que multiplica al coseno quinto de x muy
bien pero todavía no acabamos esta
derivada vamos a la mitad entonces ahora
hay que derivar la segunda función y
multiplicarla por la primera tal cual
pero cuál es la derivada de coseno
quinto de x bueno hay que utilizar la
regla de la cadena
tenemos un coseno quinto que recuerden
que cociendo quinto de x es lo mismo que
el coseno de x elevado a la quinta
potencia y espero que así ya se vea más
claro
la cual dice primero hay que derivar la
función interna la función que está
dentro de los paréntesis entonces cuál
es la derivada del coseno de x sí exacto
estás en lo correcto
bueno no sé realmente si estás en lo
correcto no sé nunca te escucho así que
no sé realmente si estás en lo correcto
pero voy a suponer que estás bien así
que la derivada del cosena de x es el
menos seno de x y voy a bajar el
exponente utilizar darle la cadena me va
a quedar 5 veces quien el coseno de x es
la cuarta o dicho de otra manera cinco
veces el coseno cuarto de x y no se les
olvide que no hemos acabado falta
multiplicar por la primera función pero
la primera función es ea la x sin
derivar así tal cual
entonces ponemos esto multiplicado por
la equis y ahora si acabamos esta
derivada y aunque podríamos simplificar
un poco más esta expresión es solamente
cuestión de álgebra bueno de hecho todo
es cuestión de álgebra pero tú captas en
la idea así que no nos detengamos más y
mejor vamos a ver más derivadas que por
cierto esta última derivada estuvo un
poco complicada porque utilizamos la
regla
y además en la misma derivada la regla
de la cadena pero bueno ahora cambiamos
a color magenta y hagamos la derivada
con respecto a x de que fíjense que
estoy utilizando otra anotación es la
anotación de que adentro del paréntesis
voy a poner la función que quiero
derivar quiero la derivada con respecto
a x de logaritmo natural de x entre el
polinomio a un polinomio sencillo voy a
tomar el polinomio 3x + 10 bien esto voy
a poner aquí el corchete vamos a derivar
toda la función que está aquí adentro y
para derivar esta función podríamos
utilizar la regla del cociente que
cuando de hecho no le hemos visto pero
después la veremos ahorita quiero que
derivamos esta función por la regla del
producto como ya habíamos hecho hace
tiempo entonces para derivar esto por la
regla del producto lo que hay que hacer
es pasar el 3x más 10 para arriba es
decir derivar esta función es lo mismo
que derivar el logaritmo natural de x
que multiplica a 3x más 10 a la menos 1
estoy pasando esta división
multiplicando al lugar y natural y
cambiando de la potencia a una potencia
negativa y ahora si al yo tendrá estas
dos funciones multiplicando se puede
utilizar la regla del producto para
derivadas entonces pues hagamos de una
vez que me dice la red del producto
agarra la primera función y deriva la
entonces cuál es la función cuál es la
derivada del logaritmo natural de x muy
bien la respuesta es 1 / x es
sorprendente esta derivada y después x
la segunda función tal cual sin derivar
igual y está como está 3 x más 10
elevado a la menos 1 ya esto hay que
agregarle la derivada de la segunda
función que sale por la regla de la
cadena y que nos dice la regla de la
cadena debemos primero lo que está
dentro del paréntesis entonces cuenta
derivada de 3x más 10 pues bueno es una
derivada muy fácil es simple y
sencillamente 3 porque la derivada de 13
x es 3 la derivada de 10 pues se va ya
esto hay que multiplicarlo por el
exponente es decir por menos 1 ponemos
un paréntesis y le restamos 1 el
exponente o sea menos 2 ok ya dentro del
paréntesis hay que poner la función
interna tal cual
y todo esto multiplicarlo por la primera
función logaritmo natural de x ok pero
ahora sí puedo simplificar la expresión
si yo veo que tengo 3 x + 10 a la menos
1 pues vamos a pasarlo para abajo me
queda 1 / x x 3 x + 10 esto es porque
estaba a la potencia menos 1 y después
me queda menos 1 por 3 por el logaritmo
natural de x pues esto es menos tres
veces el logaritmo natural de x ya esto
hay que dividirlo entre 3x más 10
elevado a la potencia 2 recuerden que
cuando pasamos los exponentes negativos
para abajo pasando positivos y aquí
están ya hemos acabado la cuarta
derivada de este vídeo así que
intentemos hacer otra derivada pero
tened en cuenta que todos estos
problemas que estamos haciendo en este
vídeo de derivadas parte 9 son problemas
que pueden enfrentarse ustedes en
derivadas en su primer medio año del
curso de cálculo entonces darse cuenta
que vamos por muy buen camino voy a
tomar la función llena ahora no de hecho
esta vez no quiero una función debería
estudiar toda la función y ahora voy a
cambiarle el nombre a p
p es la función a ver qué se me ocurre
no sé no sé
se me ocurre el seno de equis y esto lo
voy a dividir entre el coseno de x
bueno pues utilizando la misma lógica
que es la derivada de p con respecto a x
pues voy a usar lo mismo que hice en el
ejercicio pasado
voy a poner seno de x que multiplica al
coseno de x elevado a la menos 1 estoy
pasando el cociente de x multiplicando
al seno de x y ahora si utilizamos la
regla del producto es la derivada del
primero que es la derivada de senos el
coseno de x que multiplica al segundo
tal cual entonces voy a poner coseno de
x elevado a la menos 1 ya esto hay que
agregarle la derivada de la segunda
función pues la segunda función se
deriva por la regla de la cadena
entonces primero hay que poner la
derivada del coseno de x que es lo que
está dentro del paréntesis que es el
menos seno de x ya estoy multiplicando
por bajo la potencia menos 1 que
multiplica al coseno de x elevado a la
menos uno menos uno o sea la menos dos y
esto a su vez hay que multiplicarlo por
la primera función o sea por el seno de
x
muy bien voy a reducir esto con celo de
x por conceder al menos 1 de x pues es
lo mismo que coseno de x / coseno de x
pero cosas no de x entre cosas nos de x
es 1 entonces ya la necesidad de poner
nada más que 1 muy bien y después menos
x menos más entonces voy a borrar estos
menos y fíjense yo tengo seno de x que
multiplica seno de x entonces seno de x
por seno de x es seno cuadrado de x por
concepto de x al menos 2 pues es lo
mismo que seno cuadrado entre coseno
cuadrado entonces voy a poner seno
elevado al cuadrado de x / coseno
elevado al cuadrado de x pero ya se
dieron cuenta esto quien es uno más seno
cuadrado entre cocinó cuadrado pues es
tangente cuadrada entonces uno más
tangente cuadrada de equis y esto por
las identidades trigonométricas ya casi
acabamos esto es lo único que uno entre
el corsé no cuadrado de x o sea la
secante cuadrada y que creen pues eso es
cierto porque nosotros estábamos
probando que la derivada del seno de x
entre el coste no de x es decir la
tangente de x es la secante cuadrada así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo